This video is brought to you by Wix,
one of wise crack,
jared again,
and today we're talking about the enemy
that isn't sure.
Humidity has much time.
That's right.
We're taking a trip back inside the
walls and revisiting attack on Titan.
Before we get started though,
a quick shout out to us
and our first meeting you want attack on
Titan.
We piece together all the German
sounding names in the vague political
illusions to say that attack on Titan
was a show about a concept in political
theory called the friend enemy
distinction.
Check that video out,
but the Tldr is functionally that this
guy named Carl Schmidt said that friends
and enemies,
right foundational division in politics
without which some pretty bad stuff
would happen,
but we mused.
What if the show is a critique of Carl
Schmitt,
who by the way is not a nice man and got
caught up with some ad stuff.
And the third also,
we didn't read the Maga,
and today that critique habit as attack
on titan is progressed,
it became clear that these stark
division between enemy and friends,
I he tightened and human is a pretty
intense fabrication,
used to advance a specific agenda.
Seasons two and three,
explore what happens when that
distinction begins to crumble to,
can we just patch up society and go
home?
Well,
not quite.
That's because as the show explores,
even when the truth is on your side,
society has some great defense
mechanisms to uphold the status quo.
So strap on your odm gear and join us as
we go deep on attack on Titan seasons
two and three.
And as always,
spoiled ahead.
First up,
I want to say thank you to our sponsors
over at wix.
Wix is the easiest way to create
beautiful professional websites for
whatever your needs may be.
I'm actually trying to get onto the
professional voiceover game.
So I created a website with wix to
present all my voice samples.
So check it out.
I was creating a website for myself and
I wanted a portfolio and cv and I'm a
total newbie.
Then I literally started typing and
there was already a template for
voiceover artists.
I picked a style I liked,
and within minutes I was dragging and
dropping my audio files and Bam.
Now I have something I'm confident to
send out to potential clients.
Establishing yourself as a professional
in a new space can be daunting,
but I was really surprised by how
inviting and easy it was to create a
website that makes it look like I know
what I'm doing.
So if you're looking to up your game
before 2019,
go to wix.com/wise
crack or click the link in the
description to start making your free
website today and now back to the show.
Let's start with a quick recap.
Attack on Titan is about the last
vestiges of humanity hiding out behind
giant walls to avoid naked man eating
titles,
as you might imagine with giant monsters
on the outskirts of your walls are
pretty rational.
US versus them structure society.
This is a pretty high risk lifestyle and
sure enough titans breakthrough the
outermost wall.
From there,
things go from dire to downright
dystopian and it's up to the scouts,
mankind's outright or strikeforce to get
under control,
but like the city's walls,
the stark division between human and
tightened doesn't last very long.
At the end of season one,
the scouts realized that one of their
own Erin can shape shift between human
and tightened.
Also,
he might be able to use his tightened
power to seal that Pesky hold on the
outer wall.
Jonesy and custodian pull customer could
come in on Sunday.
In season two,
a bunch of titans emerge and trap the
scouts in a castle or fellow scout you
mirror turns into a titan surprise to
rescue them.
Apparently everyone is a tightened as
bertold and reiner are in fact be
colossal and armored tightened
respectively.
They kidnapped Aaron,
but the scouts are able to rescue him
and start laying out their plan to fix
the wall.
Aaron learns he can control nearby
titans and we learned that this lady,
Krista is actually named Historia,
which is very important.
Then season three happens.
Irwin,
the commander of the scouts stages a
Kuda to top by turning the people
against the nobles.
Scouts,
Aaron and Historia are kidnapped by his
story,
his father,
the true king broad rice.
They escape,
but not before rod rice becomes the
grossest tightened.
To date he attacks the city,
but Aaron and Historia kill him.
Cementing Historia as a warrior queen,
the people can get behind.
Finally,
united that people can get back to
retaking the outer wall.
Okay,
now we're all caught up,
but what do we make of all that?
Well,
as we mentioned,
attack on Titan has always been about
the distinction of being a friend and
enemy and regular speak.
It's the idea that the easiest way to
get society to work together is if
they're against someone else.
I'll season one showed a whole society
built around this principle.
Seasons two and three,
explore how people empower knowingly
manufacturer this false divide.
As such,
attack on Titan is a show about the flow
of information.
Each episode includes an interstitial
labeled information available for public
disclosure,
which implies a trove of information not
available to the public.
Some of that classified information
includes the titan inside the wall,
brother Nick,
a priest of the wall might know
something about it,
but he gets got by the interior police
before we can say too much,
and when a young Irwin talks about some
of his father's theories on history in
public,
while let's just say that no one has to
worry about waking daddy anymore.
Another critical secret is the fact that
some of these psycho killer titans are
in fact just shape shifting people.
Erin is the first example we meet,
but at the end of season one,
we see any shape shift and in season
two,
Yummier Reiner and bertold all
transform.
We even see a town where most of the
population has changed into titans.
Diego,
of course,
this is a critical secret and one,
the nobles will do anything to keep
under wraps.
That's just the tip of the
conspiratorial iceberg.
Behind the already repressive
government.
There's an even more autocratic system
that exists in the shadows.
It turns out that the king we thought
was in charge is just a figurehead.
Instead,
the city is ruled by the rice family
currently rod and his Air Storia who
have the royal blood necessary to
control the powers of the founding.
Tighten these two,
these Jewish goodwill tonight to shin.
The huc sudden powers like changing the
memory of the citizens and even creating
the walls at old sun juvenile.
No chicana down.
All of that is happening behind the
scenes determining the fate of the
people who have no idea it even exists.
The nobles go to great lengths to keep
the secret government secret.
This includes orchestrating a series of
attacks with the dual goals of
kidnapping,
Aaron and Historia for the sake of broad
Rice's plan and framing the scouts for
acting against humanities interests.
They'll go,
go,
and now you're calling.
Let me then Joseph Heron on the auto.
Cool.
Why frame the scouts?
Because between seeing several different
people turn into titans,
they realize that the founding myth of
their society,
that titans are unthinking people.
Eaters is in fact a lie,
nor does anyone bothered to mention the
role titans played in constructing the
walls that defined the world for most of
humanity.
God,
almost every choice the show makes is
premised on the withholding or discovery
of information,
Vanilla data that Ada,
Ada will,
and I have a dovetail Shinju.
That idea is so central to the show.
It's embedded into the narrative
structure.
Attack on Titan is a mystery box show
where the primary driving force,
the narrative is moving from one secret
to the next rather than moving along
narrative arcs.
It's a difficult balance,
but so far the show has pulled it off by
putting the audience in the scouts shoes
just as Aaron and Co have to decide who
to trust and what to believe.
So do we.
As we watch,
the more we learn,
the more we understand,
but the more questions we have and same
with the scouts,
but this doesn't mean people are kept
totally in the dark.
Rather the information people do get is
designed to lead them to conclusions
that support the system as is key to
that end.
There is a newspaper that provides
information to the population.
Unfortunately the only report what the
interior police tell them they should to
old companion.
This process of giving people enough
information that they don't bother to
question the structure,
providing it or the world they live in
is described by scholar Hamid Dabashi as
epistemic and docmosis were older models
of government,
assumed the lower classes were
unthinking,
illiterate,
idiots who wouldn't even know what to do
with the truth.
Dabashi argues that power can be
solidified by providing bad information
to the thinking and literate people with
the world,
the boss.
She explains that this is information to
consume,
not questioned for the more.
It's not meant to generate a coherent
body of knowledge,
but is instead single serving meant to
induce action for a specific event and
attack on Titan.
We see this in the form of state
propaganda and city newspapers.
They give people enough information that
they feel like they're making decisions
when instead they're being manipulated.
Now,
while in the real world,
this kind of epistemic in Moses
generates new knowledge on demand for
whatever benefits those in power want on
a given day.
It has a pretty singular purpose and
attack on Titan to maintain the myth of
the Titan as outsider monster.
That story enables those in power to
justify almost any action in the name of
defending the people from the monsters
outside the walls,
actions like rationing food,
limiting people's movements in a mule
non pod,
more you get,
and even attempting to execute Irwin who
was a goddamn hero,
but why lie about the titans in the
first place?
Well,
it varies from character to character,
but there are two main reasons,
power and belief,
as for power.
The city with a three wall designed to
protect against Titan attacks also
happens to be based on a strict class
structure that enables the nobles,
cushy lifestyle.
They worked to perpetuate a stratified
city suffering for resource shortages
and the occasional naked giant incident
because it's that status quo that keeps
them in mansions and fancy robes.
When Irwin orchestrates a false alarm
about a titan attack,
the nobles don't hesitate to bar
refugees from the inner wall.
Saving notion.
Don't.
No sorry,
used usage job fuck domino's.
Here's the deal.
In this moment,
we see that their interest in the system
has nothing to do with protecting the
people.
It's all about protecting themselves
without the myths that control society.
Someone might get the thinking that
having a bunch of disconnected,
rich dudes in charge might be a bad
idea.
Nice.
You got stuck out to them with data that
Missoula Udi customers a good nomi
doesn't.
The other more complicated reason is
belief.
This idea is most clearly manifested in
the character of rod rice.
Rice sincerely believes that the only
way to protect the people is to use the
power of the founding titan.
Gluten will come in or she'll take
decent Olga children.
Issue started to sick I Dakota.so
don't sweat it,
Dave,
even if that means wiping people's minds
in having his daughter eat her friend to
become a titan herself of all those
fancy powers court on Tuesday to do
connect to Janina.
The dosing can be production.
That power is so crucial to maintaining
the status quo.
That rice things.
There's no price too high to pay for it,
even his own daughter.
Thus when she rescues Aaron,
he takes the serum himself to try and
inherit the power,
but it goes awry and he almost kills
everyone.
What makes this dynamic extra
complicated is rod didn't always believe
this as a younger man,
he and his brother Yuri wanted to
destroy all the titans,
but when you're a gained the founding
titans power,
he changed his mind and concluded that
only the city could protect them,
no matter the motivation.
The problem with this heifers,
Elos way of thinking is that it turns
all political questions into ethical
questions
and you come in with untitled or take
much
for rod rice,
whether he's trying to destroy all the
titans or maintaining the myth of the
Titan.
The stakes are the existence of humanity
theory.
Strong,
tall move explains that when politics
become a referendum on ethics,
beat politics part ceases to exist in
favor of a battle between us and them.
The process is simple and attack on
Titan.
The status quo is set up as the only way
to protect humanity from the titans.
That means anyone opposed to the system
represents an existential threat
lighter.
That's what I wanted that Joseph into
that
and thus they're evil and when it comes
to evil,
there's no reasoning with it.
The only option is to fight.
For instance,
when the city turns on the scouts,
it's because these former heroes put
society in danger by questioning dogma,
so the scouts need to be destroyed.
The ultimate existential threats and
ethical enemy according to the fat cats
in this district is the titans.
Of course,
we know that's not entirely true.
After the scouts discover Connie's
village to be empty,
they realized that many of the people,
they're turned into titans including
Connie's mother,
but that doesn't matter in the face of
an ethnicized politics.
When some people or titans are
determined to be an existential threat,
the idea of understanding them goes out
the window.
Instead,
it's time to grab the swords and sliced
some vital areas.
The titans exist as threats to justify
the status quo and things to destroy as
a gesture towards safety.
That dynamic is maintained by the
control of information,
of course,
but that monopoly starts to come apart
on the personal level.
Characters are constantly forced to
choose between promises they made to
friends or themselves and the broader
life fueled social obligations.
Some characters have no issue rejecting
the morals provided by society in the
name of their own beliefs.
For instance,
Historia is unconditionally loyalty
Humira,
even though she's a type at the same
time.
Erin is driven almost entirely by the
hatred of titans.
Kelsey,
oh,
he standing.
Others are torn between these
obligations constantly like the
tightened serving in the scouts.
Birch hold,
Reiner and humira vertical and reiner
loved their fellow soldiers,
but are also bound to their duty as
warriors.
They're willing to capture Aaron,
but at the same time they do end up
letting him go.
Then they ended up with the beast
heightened setting a trap for Aaron and
the scouse Xhosa tools in the tool.
Cool.
Damn up to Dale Scott or Kudos.
They are pulled in two directions at
once,
constantly switching between the two.
Of course,
nothing in attack on Titan is simple.
As the show was saying,
more than sometimes the rules of society
conflict with personal commitment they
don't need.
Instead,
attack on Titan makes it clear that as
the social structure loses legitimacy,
whether through its failure to protect
the people or it's myths crumbling,
social bonds grow as the scouts discover
the truth,
their connection solidify to the point
of trumping their societal obligation.
That's why they go to rescue Aaron and
Historia even as society turns against
them.
Perhaps no other moment illustrates this
point better than Aaron and history is
confrontation in the cave rod rice has
aaron chained up and offers his story of
the tightened serum.
If she takes it,
she will transform,
eat her friend Aaron and become the
founding tightened that rod rice
believes the city needs.
Aaron wants her to do it.
He thinks if she eats him,
she'll be able to not only protect the
people,
but kill the titans.
Aaron spouts the city's myths.
Set the story up to convince her
secretary to hostile.
Got Kitchen.
Let's cut.
Pick you talk,
but she's not buying it.
She doesn't believe any of the social
myths anymore,
not just because she knows the truth of
the system.
Josie,
you got it,
but she also sees the moral truth.
Any social arrangement that puts her in
opposition to her best friend new mirror
is inherently wrong to her.
Okay.
Want me to $90 so she rejects rob's
plan,
smashes the vial and freeze.
Aaron.
Aaron is arguing for the status quo
while historian believes in the
possibility of a better different world.
These are the real stakes of personal
obligation versus the ethics provided by
society.
Personal ethics want to protect the
values of the people while social ethics
are designed to sustain the status quo.
Attack on Titan seasons two and three.
Point two.
The dire fact that history can be used
as a tool to tell the story that ends in
the status quo.
That's why it's so important that the
founding titans powers include the
ability to wipe the memory of the
population by creating a history that
fits their needs.
The people in charge are able to
maintain persistent control of the
population and give them ethical
priorities that matched the goals of the
system and attack on Titan society is
sustained by myths.
The powers that be will do anything to
protect those stories and justify the
status quo against the possibility of
any other social model.
Gutted.
Dylan.
Cut It on the keynote.
Was she touching?
Okay.
Kendig,
Olivia.
So data that shows that includes killing
titans even if they aren't monsters
after all,
but rather people and during a terrible
fate,
anything is justified if it means
keeping society as it is intact.
So what do you think wise?
Crack his attack on Titan.
A lesson on how power works or is there
something we missed?
Share your thoughts with the world or
create your own professional website by
clicking here to create your own free
website with wigs.
Also,
we got some great videos coming out
before the end of the year,
including ones on.
It's always sunny in Philadelphia,
the Justice League,
and one on Jrr Tolkien that we've been
working on for awhile.
So stay tuned for that.
And until next time,
peace.